我老公呢，
是这样的情况啊，
我俩是同一年的，
就是年纪是一样大的，
他是985。
就是毕业的本科高中没有念完，
然后我就自己来深圳打工了，
他现在的月收入是2.5个W，
然后他父母薪的话是有退休工资的，
自己考了中级学个8学职称，
然后还做那个函授的大专，
我父母亲是农民，
我现在月收入的话是8000这样子，
我们现在是结婚大概有八九年了吧，
孩子现在是五岁，
他之前的工作是做那个项目经理，
完了之后就需要经常出差，
他就去做那种按摩呀什么的吗，
半套，
我俩感情特别好，
然后他尊重我，
他把他自己就是公司所有的钱都给我，
他信任我，
相信我感情好，
对我好。
陈念结婚有六七年吧，
我一直都是跟他说，
哇，
我觉得我嫁给这个人太幸福了，
我一都是这么去跟他表达的，
然后我也一直坚信的相信就是他不会做一些伤害我的事情，
就在六月份的时候呢，
我就发现他，
我说这个498的足疗店的。
三岁是什么样，
然这个事情就给爆出来了，
当时我就觉得很痛苦，
痛苦了有两个月吧，
就一直在吵架，
然后呢，
他是我承诺，
因为他当时说的什么并没有实质性的发生关系，
并没有一个很严重的错误，
虽然有一点错，
但是错误并不是很大，
那我是完全不能接受这个事情的，
到了两个月之后，
我也慢慢的接受这个事情，
因为我心底还是相信的，
毕竟这么多年的感情，
然后他也并不是一个很就是从跟里跟那么的人，
但是完了之后呢，
因为我一直都不死心，
不跟一个人从一个很幸福的状态里，
然后突然就是交到一个村里去了，
那我就会整天的把你的手机看，
然后看看你还有什么其他的问题，
然后呢，
又发出来一个498，
他每次去之前他都要先吃药，
就就那种东西，
然后又吵了一个架的，
我说谁好，
人家你要去做半套服务了，
还得先吃这个呀，
所以我已经不太清楚这个后面努力到是在骗我，
还是没有在骗我，
然后这个钱到底是能做半套还是全套。
我在查的话呢，
就发现他还有20万的外债，
然后他自己已经偷偷摸摸的用年终奖已经还了10个了，
就是另外10个的话呢，
是贷款，
我查过了，
他的消费记录全都发到游戏里去了，
那遇到情况就是这样子，
他说他不肯告诉我是因为怕我离婚，
怕我离婚的话，
我说那你现在要么你就解决这个问题，
我不会管，
我也不会给你兜底了，
我记着他，
我他就去找他的妈妈，
我就过来了，
过来然后就帮他把钱给套了，
把这个事儿就给停了，
现在的情况就是这样子，
我们现在资产的况就是没有什么资产，
可能也就是还有20来个了，
都产没有，
都还没有，
因为我们在一线城市，
我觉得我们两个人的收入加起来的话，
这边的房价太高了，
买不起，
我之前一直有在打他这个钱，
他都偷偷摸摸的去把他的游戏去了，
他的人生一大爱好打游戏，
他给我的解释就是因为我们结婚了之后，
我跟他说有孩子不可以在家里打游戏，
因为你是什么样子的人，
你的孩子将来也会成为一个什么样子的人，
那你在家里天天玩，
他呃濡目染的话，
他也会一样的，
我不希望孩子变成这样子的，
他算是就是认同我的说法吧，
所以他孩子比较喜欢去出差的，
因为他他差的。
别人管他，
他可以尽情的玩游戏，
你们你那个公公婆婆是就是公公婆婆都有退休金哈，
公公还没有退休呢，
然后婆婆也退休金，
在小县城的，
现在你这个情况我我理解的是，
你也也不想跟他彻底的掰开，
彻底的分开以后啊，
我的想法是我当时跟我婆婆，
就是一开始的时候，
我都没有去跟我婆婆说这个事情完了之后呢。
就是等到20万的事情爆发了，
然后我才打电话跟婆婆说的，
我就把她前面的都掉了，
然后我婆婆的意思就是给我怎么选择，
她说如果说你一个人代表的话，
我就跟她表达，
我就是拿着8000的工资在这个地方，
我要带着我的孩子，
我还要租孩子，
我是代表她的，
然后她说，
嗯，
如果说你想要孩子的话，
我可以过去给你带，
我婆婆是很好的，
我很喜欢他，
我之所以让这个机构呢，
就是因为前面几年给我感觉太美好了，
那个你他两架的不怎么好的，
也只是到现在要出去的话，
也还是手拉手的，
你先别管三七二十一啊，
现有的这20万，
呃，
可不可以签个协议都归你呢，
不是协意，
他们愿意给我，
他已经说了，
如果说你你想要怎么选择的话，
我把钱都给你，
孩子现在多大了5岁？
男孩女孩儿呀，
男孩儿啊，
乖不乖呀，
很听话，
一家人都很喜欢他，
你们两口子要想在一线城市买房，
那路且远着呢，
嗯，
我知道是因为去年的时候呢，
我就已经表达了我不喜欢他的这份出差的工作，
我说你一直都这样子是不行的，
因为孩子毕竟还是要不亲一起的，
在我公公还子要培养嘛，
那我婆婆就是不想让他一个人待在老家，
所以我呢是自己一个人在，
然后幼儿园有托班嘛，
我下班的时候才去接他，
然后他爸爸的话是周末回来以前就是周末夫妻，
那从这个架吵完了之后呢，
他觉得他需要改变了吗？
所以他的工作他就去辞职了，
那现在在你们那个一线城市找到工作了吗？
现在还没有，
就是完全工作交接，
还要等到下个月吧，
那这个事儿咱们再缓一缓吧，
等他在跟你同一个城市找到工作了，
夫妻两口子没有，
他现在已经会这么开了，
他换工上面的事情就是因为我已经。
常亮的表达我已经不开心了，
他可能也还是比较顾及我的感受吧，
就是在领导他让他去出差的状态下，
他就说那他不能再出差了，
如果说继续出差的话，
那他们他就要辞职了，
那领导嘴上答应你说好，
但是会抄下来你他认为这种状态是不可取的，
所以就直接递了辞职书，
干职啊，
觉得这个事情啊，
因为毕竟就像你所说所说的，
曾经你们还是很美好的，
对孩子也很听话，
婆婆也很好，
然后呢，
你自己也有工作，
她的工作收入也还可以，
从你的角度综合来看的话，
再观察一段时间吧，
观察他，
嗯，
换了工作状态，
不需要出差了，
之后看两口子关系能不能弥合，
能不能修复啊。
有的时候就是需要一个契机吧。
举个例子啊，
假设有一天他现在出门被车撞死了，
你会不会觉得，
哎呀，
还是舍不得他啊？
我想过来如果说话就行，
开始的时候我不赞美这个人，
我觉得我没有更好的选择喜欢这个人的，
因为我喜欢他就是。
有学历吗？
因为我自己本身欠那个，
那我这样需要这个东西，
他就我的智商还挺高的，
学习能力很强，
我看他一是这个，
然后脾气又还挺好的，
对我很好，
就是有任何事情的话，
他会跟你商量，
就是无论是小孩子的教育，
或者说是平时生活中的事情，
但是有一个感就是我就是这两个月我认真思考了一下，
他之所以去找伴，
他是因为我前面几年没有怎么配合，
就是你拒绝他，
对，
因为我在这个事情上并不是特别的热衷，
完了之后呢。
我一直在突然就是生完孩子以后啊，
就是有思念嘛，
缝了真我不明白，
就是别人会不会有这样的感觉，
但是我后面是会痛的，
我就有几年就没怎么配合你，
你你就这么说的话，
从男人的角度来看的，
他的话我觉得也他也没那么十恶不赦，
他也没有那么坏，
我跟你讲你自己的学习很可能都是可以解决的，
我你那应该是因为我要经炒看你嘛，
可以呢，
就是大家都在说我自我QA，
因为我自己的时候，
我那底是最清楚的，
我有没有拒绝过这个事情，
或者说是我有没有很配合这个事情，
就是大家觉得我是在自我QA吗？
当我的朋友说就是人家你遇到的这个问题，
其实运营上一个大问题，
因为他把所有的钱都给你了。
那他打游戏他也没有花在其他人身上，
当一个真正的大问题出现，
有可能就是他已经跟别人有感情，
已经发生关系了，
并且把钱给别人花了，
是有一定的这个道理啊，
他还是把这钱都给我，
就是他，
他直到现在，
就是我吵完架的时候，
直到现在他还是把他所有的钱都给我，
并且他还愿意，
就是我说我没有安全感，
他让我给他手机定位啊，
把他的所有的银行卡都绑上我的微信啊，
只要一个钱我全很清楚啊，
你没事的话，
你也去那个，
嗯，
做个检查，
一方面是检查一下这个顾科啊，
看看有没有什么传染性的问题，
也没有什么传染性的问题的话，
反向也可以推导出来，
你老公没有那么严重在外面啊，
嗯，
另一方面呢，
就是看看有没有什么修复的。
这样一个比如说什么光疗啊，
什么各方面的修复一下啊，
再一个呢，
就是如果你会疼的话，
你可以就是润滑油啊什么的都了解一下，
我感觉它没有那么十恶不赦，
没有那么坏，
反正就是说没有那么不堪吧，
就是你老公，
所以这事儿，
尤其是你说你几年都跟人家没有这个夫妻的亲密的关，
看起来非常爽吧，
就是也不是完全没有，
就是非常少，
对不对，
就这这事儿的话，
他两口子要相互去，
相互去迁就一下对方的，
对你你会觉得我的想法就是。
会有，
你为你心里有困惑，
有难过，
有伤心，
这是有内耗，
这属于正常的一种现象，
但是咱们通篇听下来的话，
就那种，
我没有那么坏，
他没有那么不堪，
但还是有很多的其他的优点的，
比如说他那个照顾孩子呀，
他一直以来对你很好啊，
然后他经济上钱也都交给你了呀，
这些都是他的优点吧，
就这意思，
然后尤其是在你们夫妻两口子关系那么不和谐的状态下，
对吧，
你发现了他498的这种半套的这种状况，
我觉得你还是可以再观察观察，
尤其是不出差了啊，
两口子不在异地了，
然后你自己也调整调整自己的这个状态啊，
也多配合配合，
弥合一下夫妻的感情，
嗯，
换句话说的话，
你要再找个别人的话。
可能也不一定比他好多少。